looks like this is just another boring
day for natsuki subaru nothing ever
exciting happened oh my god
i just got transported to a fantasy
world and i'm not even gonna question it
this is amazing
i'm gonna have the greatest time ever
ever
oh my god they have irishmen here buy
this [ __ ] apple oh my god they have
naked furries here
oh my god they have generic thugs about
to beat me up here give us your [ __ ]
money
[ __ ] maine love interest incoming hi
i'm emily i'm in love with you um what
we literally just met five minutes ago
will you be my waifu what the hell is a
wife
shh it's already done i'm looking for my
insignia i think i saw it here oh god
i'm dead by this [ __ ] apple did i
just not die when i got killed that's
strange i've never met you before but i
feel i have
do you ever get that feeling of deja vu
shut up tracer oh god i'm dead play this
[ __ ] apple
okay i keep dying and waking up in front
of this guy so that means
that i have the ability to
nope still can't figure it out you can
return to a very specific point in time
every time you die i can return to a
very specific point in time
every time i die thank you thanks mr
save point guy that's actually my name
mr save point guy
i'll trade you the insignia for this
phone who the hell uses flip phones
anymore
shut the [ __ ] up you can have the
insignia over my
dead sexy body she is pretty sexy you
know shut up boner now's not the time
well it's a good thing i've got a
swordfish you said you were a swordsman
not a suicide bomber what's the
difference
mark my words you'll definitely see me
again and we'll never see her again
your twins who everyone thought were
lesbians at first yes we're so in sync
we can even finish each other's banana
damn it rim so what's the real
difference between the two of you nobody
really gives a [ __ ] about me
let me be your butler please please
please you can if you take a bath
the creepy-looking pale guy who owns
this mansion
no deal well this doesn't seem so bad i
can get used to being a butler oh god
why are you killing me
i just smell like [ __ ] is that really a
reason to kill someone
are you okay you look like you've seen a
ghost or a [ __ ] psychopath apparently
you ever get that feeling of deja vu
no i never get that [ __ ] feeling of
deja vu
but you're acting like there's a curse
and we need to find the source will this
affect amelia look you need to calm down
with this amelia obsession
if i said amelia told you to jump off a
cliff would you
i found the curse it was it was the dog
all along
i i don't get it either rem smash
you're cool now yeah are you kidding me
you killed me multiple times
like pretty [ __ ] horribly people
don't just forget that but i want your
dick now yeah we cool
subaru i'm about to go to a really big
event full of very important people got
it really big event important people yes
so whatever you do don't come inside and
do anything you can to not
embarrass me got it got it whatever i do
come inside and do anything i can to
embarrass you what that's the complete
opposite of what i said hey i hate
[ __ ] faces which one of you [ __ ]
has been [ __ ] talking my wife who emilia
oh for
[ __ ] sake silence royal candidates
introduce yourselves i'm the cute one
i'm the cool one i'm hot as [ __ ] but i'm
also a massive [ __ ] i don't even know
what i'm doing here i don't like amelia
how dare you not like amelia you fuzzy
blue eyebrow [ __ ] what did he just say
about my eyebrows
look if you all don't understand the
greatness that is emilia
you can just stand there and listen to
my top 100 reasons why amelia is a great
gal
number one hundred she has white hair to
god's once ascends i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill him melio
emilia if you're so bloody obsessed with
her why don't you just marry her already
maybe i will i did not agree with that
yes you did enough of this farce you're
blatantly white-knighting this girl in
front of literally hundreds of white
knights oh yeah
well your face is a white knight
what are you gonna do take me outside
and teach me a lesson
yeah you totally deserve that you stupid
[ __ ] i've had enough of this
i need to tell her about my power even
if it cost me my life so be it
at least for a second she'll know my
pain emilia
i can return by d um
um are you okay i can return to death
you want to return to denny's
you're hungry you want dennis i can
return to that
you want to go now you wanna you wanna
get something real quick
what i'm just trying to help you you're
being super rude right now
i can't dance
[ __ ] my life if you don't want amelia
you can always have me well hey
i didn't know the knights had hot cat
girls too actually i'm a boy
no you're [ __ ] not no really i'm i
said
no you're [ __ ] not so is the plot
going to kick in anytime soon does
suffering kind of plot
no too bad
[Music]
i just had a horrible dream i was
suffering and there was a crazy guy who
made rem play twister
and then a whale ate ram oh god ram
why do you keep doing this tourette uh
who's rem
are you [ __ ] serious are we really
doing this right now
[Music]
please tell me it can't get any worse
don't worry i'm sure i can't get any
worse
oh god why are you doing this to me
cheer up subaru let me make one of the
most heartfelt speeches in recent animes
to make you feel better cementing me as
best girl
wow i'm all better now also i love you
[ __ ] you
i love amelia
[Laughter]
what i'll kill you
also i love you i love you too really
no look how about we lighten up the mood
with uh a joke you have jokes in this
fantasy world right
sure knock knock who's there i love i
love you emilia
what is he so great about her what does
she have that i don't
she can smile she can smile
i'm not even mad maybe i should just be
with someone who's not as [ __ ] as
you are
like who like felix
i wonder what i should have for dinner
tonight also no
no more okay look whatever you want to
tell me i promise to listen after you
help me can it wait after that
fine thank god i do love amelia though
look i just need your help taking down a
whale give me one reason why i should
help you if you agree you can be best
girl
deal my fingers crossed the entire time
now let's kick some [ __ ] whale
ass
this season on whale wars
whale wars we finally did it and i
couldn't have done it without your help
uh uh rem
yeah i knew that you forgot didn't you
look i'm gonna go kill better geese now
so why don't you disappear for the rest
of the season
all right just please don't forget i
don't remember anything that just
happened but let's kill battle geese
i'm battle geez who might be tookies no
i'm battle geese wait [ __ ]
not just when we thought the suffering
was over don't worry the last respawn
point shouldn't be too far away
welcome back i'm still a boy by the way
stop
[ __ ] reminding me so what exactly is
the plan now all right i just need to
rip off an attack from another anime
spirit
gun dude
not cool man don't worry amelia i'll
save you hold on
why why why are you doing this all for
me i don't get it
i heard rabbi's head over heels in love
with you she'd do anything for you
so why are you going so far just for me
who's rest [ __ ] in the world don't
even think about it just say it ready
one
two three you what did we just become
best friends yup hey guys hope you
enjoyed that episode of anime in minutes
if you'd like to see the previous
episode which was tokyo ghoul or any
future episodes just click on the links
here
don't worry i haven't actually decided
what the next anime minutes is gonna be
yet
so all the clips you see aren't actually
indicative of what the next video is
gonna be and if you can't tell a video
like this takes a tremendous amount of
work so if you'd like to support this
continued content then you can visit my
patreon as that's a huge help from me a
huge thanks to everyone who's involved
in this project
especially my voice actors at the moment
i'm trying to find a way to make these
episodes quicker but i don't want to
sacrifice the quality i have now
so we'll see but i definitely have plans
to make many more episodes of this to
come anyway that's it for me now though
i've been gig up and i'll see you all
next time